and what that means is that you need
every company you invest in to be able
to get to about 100 million a year in
revenue what's up guys Sean here Sam is
out so I am doing this episode solo and
I'm going to do something a little bit
different I'm gonna start by talking a
little bit about some of the angel
investments I've made you know in our
Facebook group I posted something about
angel investing and a whole bunch of
glad questions and so I thought I would
come on the podcast and actually talk a
little bit about it what I wanted to
learn about angel investing I would only
ever read things from the people who had
killed it usually over the last 10 years
you know somebody like an eland Gil
Jason Calacanis talks a lot about angel
investing and I would read their stuff
and it was sort of like I'm an angel
investor I've invested in 100 companies
here's the five huge ones that you know
about where I've made millions and let
me talk to you about what I look for an
angel investing now and that was cool
but it didn't actually tell me sort of
their thought process at the beginning
how they decided to do it or how they
got started how much money it required
all those just the actual tactical
questions about doing it
I didn't hear a whole lot about that I'm
sure somebody has blogged somewhere
about it but that's what I want to talk
about because that's where I'm at you
know when it comes to angel investing I
am by no means an expert and I don't
mean that just kind of in a you know
sometimes you say something and you're
like you know but I'm not a financial
adviser don't listen to me this is not
that because when I say that that means
hey I really think this is true but
don't sue me this is I'm for real when I
say I'm not an expert meaning I'm
actually kind of like a beginner I'm
just one notch above a total beginner a
total beginner hasn't even taken any
action yet they don't know then you know
which direction they're going they're
just lost in the middle of Disneyland so
I'm one level above that where I've been
on Space Mountain but I you know I just
have a map in my hand I'm just trying to
figure it out I'm still looking for a
hot dog that Disney world analogy went
pretty far so anyways point is I'm a
beginner
I'm learning as I learn I say this stuff
out loud so there's me just learning in
public and
if somebody out there is listening
because I know a bunch of people would
listen to this there are actual
investors who have been doing this for a
long time feel free to correct me and
say hey you know that thing you said
made no sense usually do it this way
instead those are my favorite types of
messages so feel free to message me if
that's the case but all right let's talk
about angel investing so my angel
investing life started truly about six
years ago seven years ago when I first
moved to San Francisco so I moved to San
Francisco I get a job as a product
manager at a and an idea lab called
monkey inferno so p.m. kind of a boring
job p.m. but not at a boring company
this was a very interesting company was
a company that builds companies an idea
lab and I was the only product manager
there was only product guy everybody
else is an engineer and I'm making
$120,000 a year and so I don't think of
myself like an investor right 120k
living in San Francisco paying
california taxes you're not like rolling
and money at all I had a little bit of
money saved up from my previous company
but again I didn't think of myself in as
investors so the first thing was the
first lesson of angel investing was
think of yourself as an investor because
those first three or four years I was in
San Francisco I had the opportunity I
was doing mastermind dinners I was
organizing dinners and my friends were
the founders of other companies and you
know if I had just stopped working on my
company if I had stopped quit my job and
all I did was just write 20k checks to
all of those friends it might have been
I might have needed 250k but I would
have turned that into you know at least
five million dollars just off the
success of those friends companies and I
was helping them and I thought a lot of
their ideas were good I thought a lot of
them would succeed I remember I talked
to the founders of calm
early on when calm was struggling they
couldn't even raise their next round you
didn't know what was gonna happen it was
just kind of Alex toiling away and I
remember thinking hey this guy's like
really committed to this and this guy's
really creative and I think he's right
about the world like I think he's right
that a lot of people will want this a
lot of people will want to have more
calm in their life and I think people
more people will meditate and you know
there was a obviously it wasn't
clear-cut but I would have been on that
company and I would have been on six or
seven to those companies
and then several of them did really well
calm now as you know a multi-billion
dollar company so out of just that group
of friends I think there were probably
two or three companies that have reached
over five hundred million dollars in
valuation and I would have been
investing when they were like under five
so the lesson I learned four years later
was why the hell was i investing these
guys companies I believed in them I had
access to them I just didn't think of
myself in his investor the excuse I gave
myself was I didn't have the capital but
the real the reality was if you are
creative enough if you're resourceful
enough if you're persuasive enough if
you're determined enough you can get
capital you can get any resource you
need and so that actually brings me to
my first angel investment so the next
company I got really excited about fast
forward four or five years I'm still
don't you know have you know millions of
dollars in the bank to go write these
checks and I see this company called
lambda school and I had been thinking
about a product like this or a project
like this to go do myself and when I saw
it I was like whoa this guy's doing a
much better version of what I was
thinking might might work what's
something I thought about doing so I
started calling the guy start talking to
him and I told him you know I want to
invest in your company which was true
not a lie I did one invest in his
company but I didn't tell them I've
never invested in any company so I
definitely withheld that and I said tell
me about your company I want to invest
and he started sent you know sharing his
slide deck sharing the materials and I'm
like you know I have to find a way to
invest this company I thought to myself
okay I need to invest 25k in this
company okay no problem I can sell a
stock that I own or I could say I could
just take some of my savings and do this
one company was never gonna be a problem
but with angel investing you need a
portfolio of companies because you're
investing in early-stage startups this
is extremely high risk of failure so in
a portfolio of 10 companies you would
expect some kind of distribution where
you're gonna get four or five of the
companies to go to zero you know two or
three of the companies to return
somewhere between 1 and 3x and then
hopefully you know you end up with one
or two companies that actually break out
and do 10x plus ideally you get to
something that does a thousand X plus or
10,000 X plus those are that the
the early investors in uber for example
so anyways I always knew I could invest
in one company but I never you need
about 30 bets to really be you know an
angel investor to have a poor enough of
a portfolio where you give yourself a
chance to succeed
so you know I was sitting there doing
the math and I said if I need to invest
$25,000 in 30 companies I need $700,000
I didn't have that so that's why I
didn't think of myself as a Fester but
what I did was very smart
I got to give myself credit on this one
when I knew I want to invest in lam
school I said okay how do I get the
money to invest in this and so I talked
to a friend and I said who I knew invest
and I said hey at this company that I
think is really great I want to
introduce you to them and in general I
see a bunch of companies that are really
interesting and I know you like to
invest do you want to do a deal where
you know I can sort of be a scout I can
be a sort of a venture partner and an
entrepreneur who can help you with your
investments and we can set up a deal so
here's what you know the first deal we
set up was cool any deal we invest in I
get 10% carry meaning I don't have to
put any capital in I take zero financial
risk and I get 10% of the upside after
he's paid back his investment so it's
not huge returns right like Sequoia
Scouts Sequoia is one of the biggest
venture capital firms they had a scout
program and they gave 50% to their
scouts you know they were extremely
extremely generous or 45% something like
that so this wasn't that but then again
Sequoia didn't pick me they didn't even
know who the hell I was so I took what I
could get and I realized in order to get
in to get companies if you talk to one
company they want to they usually want
to know what other companies have you
invested in and so I knew I needed to
start building a portfolio of labels so
a bunch of logos that I could point to
and say yep I invested in that company I
invest in that company and that company
you would be in good company if you were
with those companies right that's the
core idea so I said let me start
building this portfolio this guy's
willing to put up all the cash I get a
piece of the upside let's do it so we
wrote the check into lambda school and
I'm very grateful to him for you know
bankrolling me in that and I think it
was a you know fair enough deal and so
we invested when it was you know it was
still a pretty expensive deal because by
the time I organized this the valuation
had gone up about 3x so I lost a 3x
returned just in the time it took me to
to get you know sort of a backer and on
the deal if it was just my own money and
I could have invested after a first
phone call I would have but anyways it's
gone up about 10 times in value since
then it's that that investment which is
illiquid but that's the sort of paper
valuation of that company today so that
was the first dip in my feet in the
water and I said alright that was good
and I made a deal with myself which is
cool I'm gonna try to invest in about
five to ten companies per year this is
what I might my goal was I said but you
know I think five is the right sweet
spot and unless I'm you know if I have
free time I'll go to ten a year but I'll
do five a year and whether it's my own
money or other people's money now I'm
thinking of myself in his invent as an
investor so that'd be the first thing I
would say to you guys is if you ever
want to invest if you ever want to be an
angel investor and play this extremely
high-risk high-reward game of startup
investing the the number one advice I
would give to you is don't wait till
you're rich to do it because at that
point you know the financial returns
it'll just be a part of a broader
portfolio it's not going to be that
exciting but if you really want to do
this start thinking of yourself as an
investor from day one and find ways to
access the capital there are ton of
people out there with capital myself
included who would love for you to be
bringing them deal flow and would
happily give you carry on any deal that
they invest in I remember there was a
guy named Suroosh who was a 13 year old
kid living in Canada and he used to use
our product we built this website called
blab it's like kind of this zoom type of
product he used to get blab all the time
and he was like he came to me and he
said hey I want to I remember with what
our arrangement was but basically I told
him I said you want to learn about this
stuff I want you to go scout out three
companies a week email me the best one
you know the best one that you saw and
why you think it would be a good
investment why you think would be a bad
investment in your kind of overall
recommendation and one of those
companies now several years later he's I
think 20 years old now so seven years
later the very first company he sent me
is a company called apply board
that just raised money at a 1.1 billion
dollar valuation he brought that email
back up to me emailed me again being
like hey why didn't you invest in this
thing I told you I gotta know you're 13
I didn't believe you
but yet there's a bunch of examples like
that where you can bring deals to other
people and if they invest you can get
karey and you could bring it to multiple
people so you don't have to be exclusive
with any one person you could say great
these five people all agree that if I
bring them a great deal they'll give me
a slice to the upside great you could
you could do that with five five
different more established investors in
any given time okay enough on that so
since then I've invested in about I've
looked at that I've looked at about 50
companies I've invested in about four or
five and some of the questions that came
up when I posted about this were you
know first question was how do you
approach these companies are they
sending stuff to you do you go reach out
to them and I told my answer this is if
you looked at the quantity I get more
coming to me than I reach out to but if
you look at quality the best stuff is me
going direct to founder or a the maker
of a product that I see that I love and
just saying hey I'm a big fan of what
you're doing like I love this I think
this could be really big you know we'd
love to chat and potentially invest in
the company and then I'd get on a phone
call and then I end up investing in
their company and so that's one way
another way is just a friend sent if now
if I have a friend who's doing something
my goal would be to be the first check
in to him there are exceptions of course
my buddy Tyler worked with me at bebo
before we got acquired and when we got
acquired he didn't want to join us he
wanted to go do a start-up I said
fantastic what are you gonna do and he
said I'm working on this crazy robotic
arm you've robotic arm for amputees you
know if you have your arm amputated
there's this amazing you know I don't
even know what you'd call prosthetic
yeah it's it's sort of a robotic
prosthetic arm that is basically you
know as close as you can get back to to
what a normal arm would be and I said
Tyler that's amazing for the world
I won't invest in that because that
sounds super hard
sounds like it's a ton of risk and I'm
just not gonna do it but most of the
times I would love to back back my
friends and so that's the other way that
I get deals okay so now somebody else
asked what is the bankroll that you
think is required to get started
I'll tell you what my answer is my
answer is I think you're gonna need to
get down 20 or 30 bets so let's take 20
as the low end and I think you want to
assume you're gonna invest $25,000 on
average into the companies typically you
can get away with a little bit less if
you need I've invested 10,000 into a
company before but 25,000 is sort of the
realistic big buy-in that you would take
you would do for for a start-up so I
take that as the average that means you
need half a million bucks but you don't
need it all up front so you might invest
in those 20 companies over a three to
four year time period
let's take four years and now you know
you need 125 thousand dollars per year
to put down the the number I would if
you need to make your check size go up
or down that's fine if you need to do it
over a slightly faster or shorter time
or a longer time period that's fine the
thing I wouldn't do less of is less
total companies so I wouldn't go below
20 bets 20 different companies because
at that point you're not letting
variants work in your favor
in fact AngelList did a study and
basically found that the best angel
investors or the you know the best
returns on average just like in the
stock market are essentially by indexing
so some individuals can be indexing but
not consistently over a long period of
time and so the same is true of startups
if you could just invest in every
credible startup that would be the way
to do it credible being a key word here
that is hard to define but whatever we
don't need to go into it okay somebody
else asked what do you look for when you
when you talk to the founders you know
how do you make your decision if you're
gonna if you're gonna make the
investment or not so here's what I said
I said you know there's a million
intangible signals that you're thinking
about and going over but really you know
it boils down to the following does this
person know what the hell they're
talking about when I talk to them do I
get this sense of confidence and
certainty that's not about the style of
the speed of speech but that the things
they're saying actually makes sense and
when you push and probe a little bit you
can tell that they've already thought
through those things they have a
thoughtful answer about it and they know
more about the subject they don't but
they know it's so much about the subject
which is what you should expect from
somebody who's building a company in a
space
the next thing I think about is are they
an executor or just a talker of course
you want an executor are they all in on
this or are they doing this as a side
project do they have a habit of quitting
projects or habit of splitting focus
like you know I don't want somebody I
invest in to go have a podcast and go
speak at conferences and do all this
other I mean some people get caught
up in that and there's a reason I
started this podcast after I sold my
company not during the last thing I
really think about is are they in touch
with reality or they a delusional
optimist with what I mean by that is do
they actually understand the main risk
and challenge of their business so like
have they correctly identified what the
big challenge is to make their their
vision come true and are they thinking
about you know do they have they
appropriately assess that risk there's a
lot of people who don't have what I call
credible view of reality they're out of
touch with reality
you know you bring something up that's a
risk they they just don't think it's a
risk and I think that's that can be a
very very big problem and so you know
the overwhelming feeling I get when I
walk away from those conversations is
either wow this person had a lot of
clarity and quality of thought about
their business or they don't and I
basically just don't invest if they
don't have clarity or quality of
thinking around their business you know
the other thing that I sort of think
about is you know what have you done in
your past so a track record of doing
interesting and unique stuff does tend
to carry forward throughout your life
and so sometimes somebody has zero
experience in a given domain but I look
at their background and they also went
into other things with zero experience
and came out six months later as a
winner as it being a leader in a space
and so I think that looking at
somebody's track record for success is
obviously a good sign just because they
don't have it doesn't mean it's it's a
bad it doesn't mean you know you
eliminate them but it is obviously a
huge huge factor if you can do it and
the other thing is you know the question
I got no this will be the last thing on
angel investing is what are the type of
returns you're looking for some people
think and Sam often talks about like he
loves great businesses that are like the
hustle so this is actually a good
example so when Sam started the hustle I
had an opportunity to invest Kassam was
a friend and
at that point I had learned invest in
your friends think of yourself as an
investor but I went to the hustles
office which was just like you know tiny
rinky-dink place and they sat me down
they walked me through the vision and I
thought to myself this is totally gonna
work
and I totally don't want to invest am I
thinking was I don't think this type of
business will generate the type of
returns I'm looking for so what do I
mean by that
angel investing works best when you put
small checks into many companies and
you're not looking for what the sort of
median return is but you're looking for
what the maximum return is you basically
need two or three winners in your
portfolio to make everything else a
rounding error and what that means is
that you need every company you invest
in to be able to get to about 100
million a year in revenue
100 million a year in revenue is a hot
there's a billion dollar company and
this isn't about greed it's about the
risk and reward profile the risk is so
high that you need winners to pay off so
so well to justify the risk that you're
taking because you're taking both you're
taking risk and in liquidity right a
startup that you invest in is probably
not gonna be liquid for seven to ten
years and so if you have an illiquid if
you have an illiquid investment that's
extremely high risk you need the payoff
to be huge to make up for those two
downsides I'll give you an example with
lambda school I realized pretty quickly
I was like okay so it sounds like the
average student is worth what you know
$25,000 for you okay so you need four
thousand students in a in a year to
generate you about a hundred million
dollars okay four thousand students I
believe you can get there that's not a
crazy number that's not four hundred
thousand so there's not four million
students four hundred thousand I think
for hunt for thousand students will take
you up on this offer at the time that I
invested I think lambda school at that
time had graduated maybe 81 people total
you know there wasn't 81 wasn't four
thousand but it was clear to me that
four thousand was an achievable number
and that four thousand would get them to
the point where they're somewhere
between 15
million dollar revenue business
depending on what the value per student
was was going to end up being and so
that was believable and that that alone
was enough justification to say write
the check in addition to Austin's an
incredible founder he spoke very clearly
about what he was doing there was
clearly evidence that their approach was
different than other people's approach
and might get a different result than
what other people other companies in the
space had gotten for example most of the
coding boot camps were in person and
lame to school was online most of the
coding boot camps were in a very short
period to read it three months and lame
the school was like a nine month program
and what ended up happening was that
most online learning things had like a
95% dropout rate people did not complete
the course and lambda school had like I
don't know what the exact numbers were
but eighty to ninety percent of people
finished the program and eighty to
ninety percent of them got jobs a
high-paying jobs and so I was like whoa
they've you know those are amazing
signals and I believe that they can get
to 4,000 students I believe they can
give that experience to 4,000 students
which would get them into a hundred
million dollar a year range so that's
what type of returns you look for and so
I assume that in a batch of 30 companies
three of them will drive 95 to 99
percent of all the returns I hope that
in the end this Nets out into you know I
put in let's call it five hundred
thousand and I I basically quadrupled to
5x my money over the seven-year period
and so you know five hundred thousand in
and let's say at five exit that's 2.5
million out and you know this is not
like the biggest craziest life change
ever but there's a chance it's much more
if you hit one of the real winners then
you know I've seen a $25,000 check turn
into twenty five million that can happen
but you you know I would say the average
or they sort of expected return of what
I would call the minimum bar of success
is to four or five X my money over a
seven-year period which Nets out I think
to like I don't know like a twenty
percent IRR or something like that
the last thing I would say is the reason
to do angel investing is not to make
money and I don't mean that in a kind of
philosophical way
what I mean by that is there's much
better ways to make money there's ways
where your money is liquid there's ways
where you have a greater chance of
greater certainty of success but I do
think angel investing gives you one
thing it gives you a front-row seat on
the future and in a way that only owning
like Boeing stock is never going to do
for you you know you can go own Apple
and you can go make 10% a year return
guaranteed and it could be liquid not
guaranteed but you know I mean good
chance of success compared to startup
investing but startup investing will
teach you a lot about business it'll
teach you a lot about people because
every decision is a judgment call about
a person and the last thing is it'll
teach you a lot about the future as you
see what different startups are doing
each one of them is pitching you a
thesis about how the future is different
than the present and I really value that
education and I think it's a much better
way to get an education I'm getting an
education from an expert who is somebody
who has seen the future and it's coming
to me and telling me what it's going to
be I'm gonna get to sit alongside every
month and get their updates about how
it's coming and the last thing is I've
skin in the game so I have money
invested in it if I'm correct and
they're correct about what the future
looks like we get paid if I'm not we get
we lose money and that's a great way to
learn that's a great feedback loop for
learning so that's everything about
angel investing that I've I don't know
learned or would want to share with you
guys that went a lot longer than I
thought if you like that we can do
another session on that you know later
just ping me I'm gonna put my Twitter in
my my email in the show notes and get in
touch that's the best way for me to know
what you like what you don't like thank
you for listening to the podcast as
always okay I'm out of here
thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
you